-I want to get serious...
-What?
-...for a s--
No, I don't.
How could I ever get serious
after that?
Alright, guys, I love everyone's
in the partying mode.
-It's Friday party.
-Oh, it's Friday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Today's Friday?
-Friday.
Oh, shoot.
-Today's Friday.
-It is Friday.
-Usually on Friday,
I check my inbox, of course.
-What else do you do?
-I return some e-mails,
and I write out
thank you notes every Friday.
-Really?
-I'm running late.
Do you guys mind?
Do you guys mind
if I write 'em out right now?
Is that okay during the show?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I understand.
I appreciate this.
James, can I get some thank
you note writing music, please?
[ Piano rendition of
"Celebration" plays ]
-♪ Whoo-hoo ♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] God.
What is going --
Like a baby -- That was
a lullaby Kool & The Gang.
It was like, "Alright.
Go to sleep, everybody."
[ Laughter ]
[ Piano rendition of
"Celebration" plays ]
-Alright, shh!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Shh-shh!
That's the most excited
I've ever seen James.
♪♪
-Thank you,
Travis and Jason Kelce,
for being two brothers
wearing red and green,
making you the Mario and Luigi
of the NFL.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, come on.
"It's-a me, Travis."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, the word
"tailgate,"
for being a parking lot party
but also sounding like the name
of a Trump scandal
we never got to.
He's like, "I've got nothing
to do with tailgates."
-"There's a lot of tail" --
-"I was not even --
I wasn't even there
for tailgates."
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, US military,
for shooting down
China's spy balloon.
I just feel bad for the guy
who spent six months
blowing it up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Balloon deflates ]
The whole time, I wasn't
squeezing it to get the air.
The --
♪♪
Thank you, entire Super Bowl
stadium made out of snacks,
for being an impressive way
to show your friends
that you love football
and have way too much free time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"...and pretzels
and carrots.
Celery's there."
-[ Nasally ] This soppressata
represents --
-[ Nasally ] What I do
is I take a Dorito
and put it
inside of a pretzel.
-Well, I use pretzel man as --
-And I dip the whole pretzel
in the nacho --
the the nacho cheese.
It says --
-Really?
-Yeah, it's pretty funny.
Well, you get the nacho cheese
to a certain temperature,
And it will melt, of course,
and then cool off.
-Yeah, it will solidify
a different way,
making a different texture.
-Yeah, so it starts as a liquid.
Ends up a solid in your mouth,
then it becomes a liquid again.
-I know, exactly.
Then it ends up as a gas.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Celebrate good
times, you know what I mean?
-[ Normal voice ] Mm-hmm.
♪♪
Thank you,
the City of Philadelphia.
Win or lose,
it was nice knowing you.
Yeah. Good luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
Please don't --
-Come on, come on. Philly,
come on, Philly.
Please.
-"You got a hoagie" --
-Please keep it cool.
Come on, guys.
♪♪
Thank you, Doritos spending
$7 million on Super Bowl ads,
for vastly overestimating
the amount of effort
it takes to get me
to buy Doritos.
I love Doritos.
-More?
-I'm good.
-Wait, you know what?
-They're part
of a balanced meal.
-Maybe I should get
some Doritos.
Hadn't thought about it.
-I have them in the morning
in a bowl with milk, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Chiefs mascot KC Wolf.
I'm not sure what a raccoon
on bath salts
has to do
with football or Chiefs,
but I'm willing to go for it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it.
[ Shrieking ]
"Football!"
-[ Laughs ]
-Sandler's the mascot?
-[ As Adam Sandler ] Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Aw, is this the last one?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the final --
This is the final one?
-Thank you, "Last of Us" zombie,
for looking like
that one weird chicken wing
on the tray that no one eats.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank you notes.